it was your father's last wish that your
dick is grave what
[Music]
our father is dead his last wish was
that his sons attend his funeral Marina
has to go he's dead
he'll never know you're a very tender
man you know that
okay your father's last will it was his
wish that you dig his grave
what
the old man was always screwing with us
but forgiveness is good
I want to show you the casket that your
father pre-selected
the cheapest man who ever lived
hi how did you know our father we were
lovers for a while
what was he like as a father The Worst
by the weight on my chest
forgiveness is good
hi guys this is my son Simon Raymond and
Ray
your brothers
hello
hey
we come from chaos
our father was a monster and we repeat
we repeat
read them after
[Music]
growing up my brother and I we're
connecting it to him
and then just being near each other is a
reminder of all that pain
in my life
I want to know what it feels like
letting it go
but I'm scared it's going to crush me
come with me
okay
but it's gonna take a whole lot more
than a hole in the ground to get the old
man out of your head
[Music]